what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today we're going to be
looking at the nine red scabbards
and their powers as we approach the
climactic fight against Orochi and Kaito
I thought it would be useful to go over
the nine red scabbards who've already
played such an important role and will
continue to play an important role in
the 1o arc if you enjoyed these one
piece videos and you want to keep them
coming the best thing you can do is
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece of videos feel
free to suggest future videos I've
already done videos for the young cold
war lords Admirals and supernovas which
you can check out in the description
below keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video now without
further ado let's jump into it the nine
rat Scabbers are a group of samurai who
served Odin Kazuki when he was alive the
squad is still serving as vassals
of the closu ki family but it should be
mentioned that there was a traitor among
them who was not in reality serving Odin
or his family but rather Orochi we will
get into that person later for now all
you to know is that this group is led by
Kenan and consists of powerful samurai
who were seen as being Odin's most loyal
and strongest followers for instance
Kinnaman sedan judo Asura doji and
Cowell Matsu had the strength of a
hundred samurai let's start with column
a to the Kaaba a fish man who is the
highest rank you can get in sumo
wrestling Kalamata was imprisoned by the
beast pirates for 13 years but he says
that compared to the suffering of his
lord Odin the whole stay was but a
pleasant breeze as a kid the both
carrying Komatsu and his mother's sake
they washed up on 100 and tried to get
help but people threw rocks at them
calling them Fishman his mother died and
told him that Fishman are oppressed all
over the world so he should claim to be
a kapa which is an amphibious imp from
Japanese folklore interestingly enough
Kappa are said to love cucumbers and
sumo wrestling Komatsu and the minks in
watashi and nekomamushi were saved by
odin from being executed by a mob who
viewed them as monsters even though they
were just kids
after that they chose to remain with
Odin as his
[ __ ] when the Odin Castle burned
Komatsu helped save Odin's daughter here
it he used his Fishman powers to escape
with her using the moat he took care of
Puri until she was 13 years old in
addition to being the most skilled sumo
wrestler in 1o Co Amato is resilient
when kelmot's who looked after her he
gave most food he found to he OD and
starved himself and he was able to
survive eating poisonous fish every day
in prison fish that were meant to be
used for executions
Komatsu is amazing with his sword called
Soto Musa he's found a way to
incorporate his powerful fish man's
strength in sumo skills into his
swordsmanship he easily beats a bunch of
Beast pirates when he's released from
his prison and raizo even says that he
hasn't gotten rusty despite spending so
many years in prison feeding on nothing
but poisonous fish very impressive when
he was in prison they also had to take
the bones out of the fish they gave him
because if they didn't he would fire the
fish bones with remarkable precision and
take down prison guards Komatsu can also
use armament haki next let's look at the
40 year-old
nekoma mushi the feline mink and the
ruler of the night he is the leader of
the Whale forest Guardians and he ruled
the mo kamo dukedom from 6 p.m. to 6
a.m. and then switched within watashi
under Odin he was temporarily a member
of the white beard pirates and Roger
pirates
nakooma mushi is equal in strength to
his daytime canine counterpart in
watashi so their battles and in
stalemate
they fought because they both blamed
each other for Odin's death going so far
as to accuse the other of being the spy
as I mentioned when talking about kawasu
both nekomamushi and inuarashi were
saved by odin so they had a deep love
and respect for him nekomamushi and
inuarashi were strong enough to fight
with one of titles all stars Jack who
has a bounty of 1 billion varies the
fight dragged on and on the fifth day
Jack finally used poison gas to win the
10 feet 5 inches tall
nakooma mushi is even intimidating
enough to scare the super nova capone
Vasia who calls him a monster and with
good reason Akuma mushi was strong
enough to flip Jack in his mane
form which is insanely impressive after
being poisoned
he still had enough energy to scare his
torturers and almost break his chains he
can use the very cool power electro that
all banks can use electro lets a mink
channel electricity through parts of
their body or through their weapons
nakooma mushi uses the in conjunction
with his staff electro enhances the
power of attacks and allows minks to
shock burn and paralyze their opponents
nekoma mushi can also use observation
haki and armament haki he did lose a
hand to the beast pirates but he still
appears to be equally matched with in
watashi who lost the leg so next let's
look at in watashi since his story is
practically the same as nekoma mu she's
he's a ten feet six and a half inches
tall canine mink and the ruler of the
day from 6 a.m. to 6 p.m. of the mo kamo
dukedom you know what a she is the
leader of the in watashi musketeer squad
1 the refers to him as the greatest
fighter in their land although as we
know he's always evenly matched with
nekoma mushi whereas the kuma mu she was
able to fight evenly against Jack during
the night you know her ah she was able
to fight evenly with him during the day
until the poisoning he's an excellent
swordsman and he channels electro
through his sword to make his attacks
even more powerful you know what a she
cross swords with our shadow ji and
appeared to be skilled enough to fight
on equal terms with Ashura even though
he'd already lost one leg another
impressive feat especially when you
consider how much keenham own values a
shras strength in wha da she can also
use observation armament haki next let's
look at the 56 year old ash radhaji who
returned to being a criminal at Rodin's
death under the name shootin maru he's
the leader of the mount Asama thieves at
first Asha is reluctant to join back up
with the 9 scabbards but after Yahoo's
death he changes his mind when Odin
first met Astra back in the day Asha was
considered to be the strongest monster
in the lawless land of Kuti and as a
result he had a bunch of lawless
followers it took a day but Odin beat a
shrah and his men then he became the
daimyo of Kuti
and Asura became his retainer hoody once
a lawless wasteland became a peaceful
home under Odin's leadership in terms of
power a shras one of the three
birds along with Kalamazoo and and you
know who is said to be worth the
strength of 100 men even yong-chol Kaido
referred to as the strongest creature in
the world wants to recruit him hold them
a headliner of the beast pirates even
assumes that luffy is a follower of
shootin motto which again is ashes
criminal alias as i mentioned when
talked about in washy the two appeared
to fight equally Ostra also fought
against the 1 billion bounty man Jack
one of Cairo's three strongest men
Ashura gave him a solid wound on his
chest
then they clashed a bit before Kaido
showed up in Ostrava as strong as he is
knew it was time to peace out he knows
he isn't on kaido's level but he was
fine after the fight with Jack everyone
watching the fight between Jack and
Ashura could see that it was a
high-level battle so yeah don't mess
with a Shura the expert swordsman
despite his age and large size he is
fast and strong enough to leave a pirate
with a billion Barre bounty needing
bandages next let's look at rise o of
the Mist rise o used to be a member of
the closu ki Ninja squad but quit after
a kunoichi a.k.a female ninja turned him
down he was a mountain bandit for a
while and the rumor was that he beat up
men and kidnapped women however Raizel
was quick to join Odin when they found
him in the forest of udon along with the
others he became his retainer Raisa was
a master of ninjutsu and was referred to
as a genius ninja even in his youth rise
o is a master of stealth he can
successfully infiltrate the prison steal
some keys and escape with them without
being captured he can virtually
infiltrate any place get what he needs
and get out
he has great aim he can send keys in a
katana flying to Kalamazoo from a
distance fast enough for him to unlock
himself before the enemies can kill him
he's also like a walking reference to
Naruto
since Rizzo can vanish in a cloud of
smoke create clones and throw surely ken
with the best of them he may not be the
strongest but he's the best at what he
does and for that reason he's an
invaluable member of the nine scabbards
next let's look at kikunojo of the
lingering snow Kiku is actually the
younger sibling of ezel the commander of
the sixteenth of vision of the white
beard pirates after travelling into the
future with Kenan
and the rest kikunojo became a tea house
waitress going by the alias
o'kiku Kiku's brave and immediately
rushes to the rescue when Tama is
kidnapped by the beast pirates Odin
saved both cocoon and ezel in the past
their father was arrested and their
family split apart leaving them to dance
for money they were poor and starving
and Odin fed them and took them in they
both became his retainers kikunojo is a
very skilled swordsman and can easily
take down multiple members of the beasts
pirates and enemies samurai besides
being good at fighting kikunojo is good
at healing Kiku helped Zorro with
injuries and tended to Tama after she
drank the poisoned river water although
Kiku is very skilled we haven't seen any
super crazy feats like fighting equally
with one of Kalos all-stars and if you
didn't know by now kikunojo is
biologically male but and I quote a
woman at heart and quote this explains
why kikunojo is known by the people of
wah know as the most handsome swordsman
in the land let's look at the 36
year-old Foxfire keen mo next the leader
of the nine scabbards kina moans at all
dude at nine feet and 8 inches tall he
used to be a thug before he joined Odin
Kingdom on messed up one day in what
became known as the mound God incident
in order to get money Kinnaman kidnapped
a baby boar from some other guys who
kidnapped a baby boy first the giant
boar known as the mountain God came
looking for its child it caused a lot of
destruction a lot of people while
looking for keenham on the boar even a
true the woman came on stole from but
also loved then Odin came to the rescue
he sliced open the boar and saved
everyone that was eaten he even took the
blame for the incident not allowing keen
Emlyn to take responsibility for its
actions it churned surprised you that
after Odin saved him and his future wife
in the coolest manner possible Kingdom
owned along with his close friend Dan
judo decided to follow Odin they became
his servants and eventually his
retainers kena Moon is one of the Time
Traveler's in terms of power kena moon
can cut through steel slow down though
flamingos birdcage with a hockey and
Bude sold answer I've a battle with a
giant boar at a younger less-experienced
age he's intelligent coming up with most
of the battle plans
times he's so smart even fools himself
as we saw when he misread Yahoo's
message he's a master of disguise and he
even pulled off a quite humorous
doflamingo disguise in the past his
upper body without its head was good
enough at swordsmanship to clash with
Brooke and sent him running keenum own
sword style is called Foxfire style and
it allows him to not only slice but also
burn his enemies he can send fire at
opponents with his slashes or cut
through the fire in addition to his
impressive swordsmanship skills Keenan
moon also has devil fruit powers he ate
the Fuuka Fuuka no me a Kade the garb
garb fruit it lets him use small things
like leaves and stones to create
clothing this can let him create
effective disguises but he must
correctly imagine the clothing first
Keenan moon can also create battle armor
and matching weapons like swords kena
moon can use both observation armament
haki observation haki is what allowed
him to sense people and fight with on
his head an armament haki allowed him to
hold back dole flamingoes strings and
impressive feat since these strings
could effortlessly cut through hard
materials like cannonballs thus you can
see that Zorro's sword buddy kena moon
is strong and deserves to be the leader
of the nine scabbards he's up there with
the strongest of the closu key retainers
next let's look at kena moans friend Dan
judo who was present during the giant
boar incident he is not one of the Time
Traveler's he stayed behind his grief
led to a change in appearance and he
became Toshiro the Yakuza boss his own
followers are referred to as the Kyoshi
a family thank Josh Lina pretended to be
on Orochi side serving as his
moneychanger secretly he was on the
Kazuki family side the entire time he
was also like Robin Hood wearing a
disguise he used to steal from the rich
and give to the poor except people refer
to him as who she meets ooh causal
instead of one or Robin Hood for the
past 13 years
he also took care of Odin's daughter
Healy keeping her true identity a secret
he only revealed his true identity
recently to ki naman and the others on
the night of the attack he waited so
long because he didn't want the traitor
to pass on the truth to an or Qi Dan
Jenner truly kept his enemies closer
than his friends and it paid off
strength-wise dangerous a beast as
I mentioned he's one of the three that
Kinnaman singled out for being
especially strong along with Kabul
Matsui and Ashura we recently saw they
could slice a giant ship with ease if he
wants to he was even able to stop her
boys or O's flying / no small feat then
he prevents Zorro from following Adachi
using his swordsmanship keep in mind he
doesn't actually want to hurt Zorro here
so this is not even him going full out
although Zorro isn't either since he
doesn't even have his third sword
nevertheless after being trained by the
world's greatest swordsman mihawk Zorro
as observers note is able to keep up
with kyoshiro but not overpower him
being able to do so well against Oro
using a sword no less is insane and it
really gives us a sense of how strong
dan judo is danger as kyoshiro had a lot
of prestige among the beast pirates to
the point where Paige won one of kaitos
flying six headliners refer to him as
boss yoshua bengio is really the MVP of
the 100 arc in a lot of ways he was
intelligent and skilled enough to trick
the paranoid Orochi
even while he was stealing from the rich
and giving to the poor he always found a
way to keep here he's safe and he waited
until the right time to reveal his
identity he got himself in a position
where he could free samurai prisoners
and be the most service to the closu key
cause his incredible strength is just
one part of the value he's bringing last
up we have the 39 year-old evening
shower conjugal the trader himself he
was one of the Time Traveler's contro is
actually a kudos Umi like kodachi
members of the kudos Umi family were
discriminated against and killed because
the head of the kudos Umi family tried
to kill the other daimyo to become the
salt ruler of wha no the truth was
revealed and as a result not only was
the kudos Umi family not a prominent
family anymore
they were also hunted down and killed
even members of the kudos Umi family who
had nothing to do with the plotted
assassinations were killed
Kandra was born into a theatre troupe
and lost his parents on stage they were
killed because they were kudos UMI's so
understandably Kandra was upset because
his parents who had nothing to do with
the plot to assassinate the other demos
were murdered in cold blood well it all
she took advantage of these
circumstances and asked Angela to become
his spy he told him to play the ultimate
Rolle Orochi told control to live his
life as a Kazuki and to die as a Kazuki
then he gave him a devil fruit Odin ran
into kanjuro when he was collecting hair
from people in order to make
paintbrushes he tried to steal Odin's
hair but Odin kicked his butt and then
kanjuro started following him like the
other retainers contrl told odin that he
was persecuted in the past for making
paintbrushes out of human hair but he
didn't tell him that he and his family
were persecuted much worse for being
kudos UMI's
when otogi borrowed money from Odin
Castle Kandra would bring him double
from the safe Kandra would send Orochi
info all the while he was even ready to
die along with the other scabbards
during the execution that's how
committed he was to his role it was not
until after the scabbards headed out on
a ship to onegai shima that Kandra threw
one of his drawings told them the truth
and he only stopped the act because what
all she told him - he kidnapped momen
escaped and is ready to deliver him to
Adachi if he gets a chance contra is
quite strong his weapon of choice is a
giant ink brush in the past he imbued it
with armament haki and helped slow down
the flamingo's birdcage with it he can
also use observation haki his acting
skills are second to none and he was
able to trick the others until he
finally told him the truth his devil
fruit the one Oh Lord she gave him
allows him to bring his drawings to life
he can also become a drawing in order to
hide from others contra pretended he was
bad at drawing in order to trick the
closu he caused in reality he is even
skilled enough to create lifelike human
beings which he can control chondros
drawing was so good that no one aboard
the ship tonig Ashima knew that the
conjurer before them was a drawing
conjurus power is perfect for sending
messages to an or Chi especially because
no scabbard would suspect lifelike
creatures to be carrying messages from
conjure Oh his drawings of snakes are
strong enough to bind Shinobu which is
very impressive in and of itself this
power is great because it's so versatile
you could create birds and then fly on
top of their backs or draw people and
use them for espionage purposes it's
arguably one of the most useful powers
in one piece when in the hands of a
skilled artist
so that's chondros character empowers I
think what I did a really good job with
him I find the idea of a character
willing to die playing a
all fascinating and order did a great
job with chondros backstory which
actually makes his subsequent actions
believable and that is it for the nine
read scabbards and their powers
explained I did this video in part
because we've been in wanna for a while
now and I wanted to remind myself about
every character as important as we head
towards a climactic battle against otogi
and Kaito I hope you got value from it
too if you enjoyed it and want to see
more one piece videos like it the best
thing you can do is smash that like
button share this video if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos as always
leave suggestions for future videos
in the comments below lastly the YouTube
ad rates have significantly dropped
recently so the help and support we're
getting from our anime uproar patrons is
now more important than ever a very
special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legends acknowledged by Lord
we go himself baby ray and Efrain a and
the one-tier patrons the ones who stand
atop all clans Steven and Rana a Lola
nitendo world stealers the school bus
Theisen Kirino acquire respect at a
hefyd Jonathan King does Edie and
Brandon of Isles and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King's
I'll just Anatoly Kazansky angel Cruz
theme Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket XP
Tendo Ted's altar Joe Stanton very Gucci
Alicia actor animal 69 Jessica Calif on
he no kami and water
Bonnie parks is Odie are 12 wrath to
Endora Emperor otaku JCCC waka the coach
and according to Google Translate the
Chinese characters for Emperor thank you
all so much and I love to see how global
this community has become if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon accomplish anime
out Pro and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out
patreon.com/lenguin
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]